hey what's up theo this is uh jj from
denver colorado
what's up jj from denver
appreciate you calling man you know i
love denver a lot of beautiful people
over there
met a beautiful woman over there by the
whole foods there
and got her number and she never
messaged me back but
that's my life baby you feel me i still
got that number
i think it was her number could have
been a fake number bro but at least i
got a fake number
son gang baby
onward just sitting here uh listening to
this past weekend
working from home uh getting ready for a
backpacking trip to kind of
get away and clear my mind from all this
crazy [ __ ] going on
good for you brother good for you man
that's that's beautiful homework
i was just kind of curious what your
opinion is on how people can affect
change i know at least in denver they're
having a lot of uh
mostly peaceful protests which seems
like it's working pretty good
we have a police reform coming up soon
and i'm just curious if you think that
voting is the only way to affect change
or
or kind of what you think would be the
best way to go about that because it
seems like
a lot of people are hurting and they're
trying to get things changed but no
one's really listening to them
gang bro thank you for the call you know
it's interesting man
you know i find that the biggest
effector of changes really is time
um and you know you can't just depend on
time
you know you have to remind time of what
you want
and i think you see a lot of that
recently with you know a lot of the
protests a lot of
you know you see a lot of it
you know just to you know remind for
people to
share what they feel and get out there
and share what their feelings are
um so yeah i think that that kind of
stuff is good i think
voting for people that
you know yeah that you know support the
things you want
um
but it's hard i think the biggest things
that we can do because look i want to
get the the place not to do it is
arguing online it just it doesn't
it you can't win you know i got into
you know i usually do a good job of not
doing it and then the other day i
commented on something
on my social media and um
and it just you know sometimes you just
you know you want to it's weird because
sometimes you feel
online and in social media you feel
you know people behave ways online that
they're not really behaving in real life
which is interesting
and i might be going off topic i don't
even know exactly what i'm talking about
but
um but i find it say and i'll do the
same it's like
would i really go off on somebody or you
know
um i think some of the stuff is good i
think some of it though like people
start to use
uh you know like i think reminding
people
of diversity and that you know the
diversity is important
you know if you're talking about the
black live matter rallies and stuff that
that stuff
it's important is super important you
know
i think i think some of the reform for
police departments is good
i think i like the idea of there being
if there are people that have mental
health issues
you don't that the police aren't the
ones that have to deal with it
man i feel bad a lot of times when i see
police officers and i see this
all the time in los angeles police
officers having to deal with
homeless people and people who are
mentally unwell
because it's just a lot of pressure on
on cops
you know and the way that they're
trained a lot of their training is
probably more
in tactical combatical type training
and so even just seeing them having to
spend their time doing it you can tell a
lot of times the officers want to you
know they want to
help be helpful but to if they could
spend you know they could probably
definitely better spend that time
elsewhere and not have as much stress
so that kind of stuff i like um
so yeah i think some of those things are
good you know i think you're going to
see good come out of these types of
things
i think you also see bad come out of
these types of things you see people
you know trying to
i don't know man you see people trying
to where it's not about equality some
people want to make it about control
you know i feel like a lot of times i
felt attacked just as a white person in
the past month
really um
you know i don't support any type of
supremacy that's what i don't support i
don't support
you know white supremacy black supremacy
jewish supremacy
you know iranian supreme i don't support
any
uh that kind of stuff when people are
trying to control you
you know that's when people start to
make things about themselves
um and it's not about a conversation
it's just about them
people controlling you that's the part
that gets that doesn't affect i feel
like that just creates
animosity um
but i like i like the way that your
handling is man to go and spend some
time you know taking a break
uh because i think in the end still the
way that we can
best affect change changes we can affect
it within ourselves
um and then we can
affect it you know help affect it in and
be a part of
the loved ones around us you know but
really it's in ourselves
because it's hard to make somebody do
anything you really can't
and so you just do you know you affect
it within yourselves
um it's the same thing i think about the
masks a lot of times
you know people say you're not people
aren't wearing men well that's it that
you can't control that what you can
control is if you wear a mask
so that's why i say you know just
just that fight the going for the fight
somebody you know we just get caught up
in fighting and that's
that kind of stuff is it's just not
helpful to us and i don't think it
generally it makes anybody feel good
i also think that you should have to
have a
some type of
i don't know if it's education or
or degr i don't know if degree wouldn't
really be fair i don't know what it
should be to have social media
um but that's a whole different topic
and maybe that's a bad idea
you know i don't know uh but anyway man
i like what you're doing man going out
there and affecting yourself that's all
we can really do
um you know and sometimes i think a lot
of the
the stuff that's been going on it's not
hell it's not helpful
you know i'll have a friends that are
you know of both races who are suddenly
activists
and that's bizarre to me like
they're angrier than usual
and that's you know i i don't know if
that's
i don't know it just seems that like
that's not good
um
you know it's like well you weren't an
activist before you
just you know and that's scary when i
start to even find myself i'm
am i becoming like a activist like i
understand standing up for yourself and
just sharing with you what you're
feeling and thinking
i don't know it's interesting man
there's a lot going on
but in the end for me the only the only
real way i know it'll probably affect
change is to just
try to affect it within myself uh
and affect how i'm reacting to the
environment that's around me
um and yeah and to vote
um and to work hard
oh so those are things man those are
things that i'm just thinking about and
none of that is
you know i'm not trying to say i know
anything
um because that's that is the last thing
i'm trying to say is that i know
anything
but i'm just trying to share what i'm
kind of feeling man good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one
ah